Mike Cody now we're sending you back to
your home for just to make an iconic
weapon from history that weapon is
the pipe tomahawk
Tom Hawks are a First Nations weapon the
pipe Tomahawk served as both a practical
and ceremonial tool among Northeastern
Native Americans This variation on the
tomahawk symbolized both War and Peace
with a deadly ax head on one side and
ceremonial smoking pipe on the other
original tomahawks were made from wood
and sharpened stones but in the 16th
century metal heads were introduced
thanks to trading with the newly arrived
European settlers
this deadly weapon was light and Nimble
making it lethal for both chopping and
throwing
the versatility of the pipe Tomahawk can
be seen in the film The Last of the
Mohicans
your final challenge is to forge a pair
of pipe tomahawks they must be effective
working fully functional versions of the
pipe tomahawks that you see here when I
say working you got to be able to smoke
gents good luck we'll see you in five
days
my name is Cody Craig some people have
been blessed with a silver tongue I have
not but I've been blessed with Silver
Falls because I can make a lot of things
and I have such a diverse background
that could really give me an edge today
I'm just going to try and accomplish
getting this big round stock down about
an inch and a half Square that'll be
closer to the final dimensions for the
hawk so I'll be able to work them a
little easier once I'm there heat and
Ham Den Hammer the quench goes wrong you
have to start over here we go and so
that's very stressful and in
number one appears to be good and here
comes number two
no love Pops in this one either I just
gave birth to a pair of twin boy
tomahawks I suppose so making tomahawks
that are smokable super unique parameter
they found a bit that electricians use
to run long cables like through walls
it's 24 inches long make sure it didn't
go through side
which I definitely did so I got some ax
handles made out of Ash I'm gonna shape
them down to be Tomahawk handles and
then I'm gonna split them in half and
draw out the groups overall it's been
fairly tedious having to go back and
forth just to make sure they match I
mean doing it once is one thing but
having a system to be able to do it
multiple times is different I'm gonna
take a break from Tom walks for a long
while
foreign
I'm a teacher and a coach 7th and 8th
grade girls basketball I am very
competitive and I figure if I just beat
one person per round I can win you never
know what the mask is I mean it's always
a risk but it's a risk I'm willing to
take fillets are going in
full speed
I'm drifting the holes to be able to
attach the handle later and
see it tear out and my heart just
freaking drops to the soles of my feet I
got over exuberant was hitting it too
hard instead of keeping it up to
temperature I have to start completely
over because it is a matching pair
so stinking frustrating I refuse to be
the first person on forging fire to not
hand in finished weapons and so I go to
plan B which is simply make a pair of
Pike tomahawks out of fairies brass I
cut up pretty quickly all I've got to do
today is fit the tomahawk head to the
handles and punch a hole through the top
of the handle
to ensure that it will draw smoke
[Music]
gentlemen your weapons will now be put
through a series of tests but up first
the smoke test you guys ready
I'm not a smoker so they didn't actually
smoke out of it but this is the one test
that I am Uber confident on ready three
[Music]
okay
[Music]
works all right smoke test is good
one test down three more to go
blade Smiths this is the kill test
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I'll take a tomahawks and
go ham on this big carcasses
my CareFirst you ready yes sir
let's see
what's up
that was awesome
all right Mike these are made to chop
deep it's easy to maneuver and deliver
that kind of damage overall sir your
weapons will kill good job thank you all
right Cody you're up next you ready for
this yes sir let's do it
foreign
about your pipe tomahawks right here the
brass accents you have on the handle
does make for a very good grip it chops
deep it slices most importantly your
pipe tomahawks are will kill good job
thank you
all right gentlemen to test the strength
of your weapons I'll be throwing them
multiple times into our wooden Target
here Mike here first you ready yes sir
okay
foreign
Mike so right off these have a really
good feel to them comfortable handle
they're very symmetrical blade on this
one held up beautifully this one has a
bit of a delamination right down here at
the bottom and then you've got that
other delamination on the edge but it's
not coming apart it doesn't appear to be
affecting the Integrity of the blade
those pieces are still tight so
excellent job thank you all right Cody
you're up are you ready yes sir
really bad
that was awesome
[Music]
hi Cody these look very Stout but
they're feel very light
I see no damage on on either awesome
what happened uh I didn't follow the old
adage measure twice cut once the the
difference in length is probably an inch
didn't really affect the throw at all
they're solid pieces they're strong they
throw gray oh it's actually gone thank
you
the tomahawk was originally a native
weapon adopted by the early Americans in
the revolution against the British
Colonials to see how sharp your weapons
are I'm gonna take your tomahawks and
try to penetrate these red coats
Mike you're first you ready yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
sick oh my God you're a tomahawk sir as
you can see are sharp they cut easily
into these red coats it will cut yes
good job thank you all right Cody you're
up are you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
all right Cody your tomahawks our
pleasure to wield they feel good and I
can index
you're a Tom oxer will cut thank you
Mike Cody you're both badass American
bladesmiths however in this competition
there can only be one forged and fire
champion and that champion is
Mike
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire Champion Cody unfortunately
your tomahawks did not make the cut Cody
these are the kind of competitions we
love seeing or two blades Smiths make
weapons that perform almost identically
and it came down to symmetry we asked
for a matched pair of tomahawks and that
cemetery is what cost it yep all right
Cody at this time I have to ask you to
please surrender your weapons
big shout out a big congrats to Mike you
know you brought you're a game I brought
my a game and clearly you're just a
little better at measuring than I am
Mike congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that is the
title that comes with a check for how
much ten thousand dollars that's right
ten thousand dollars buddy please
present your tomahawks to the judges
I'm forged in freaking fire champion and
it feels amazing I can't even believe it
I can't stop smiling dude I'm trying not
to
foreign